Hunter Biden giving the big guy another
big headache new emails revealed
President Biden's involvement with his
son's Shady entanglements Joe wrote a
college recommendation letter for the
son of Hunter's Chinese business partner
this comes amid growing calls for a
special counsel to probe all of hunters
crooked dealings the White House though
stonewalling like crazy
was it common for President Biden to do
favors for Hunter Biden's international
business partners like writing College
recommendations for their kids I've seen
the report I have no confirmation or
comment on a report about whether or not
the president when he was a private
citizen wrote a college recommendation
letter for an individual but he's the
president now and you're his
spokesperson
correct and he was not the president at
the time of this report
and Chris Christie shredding the corrupt
media
we know what the Democrats would be
saying if this were going on in a
republican Administration and so what we
need is to get to the bottom of it and
let's face it the media has been
complicit in this they didn't want it to
interfere with their narrative that Joe
Biden deserved to be elected president
this is where we are right now and we
need to get to the bottom of it and get
to the truth all right judge let's get
to the truth here so Biden flies Hunter
to Beijing and Hunter introduces him to
this guy and then a couple years later
Biden writes a letter recommendation to
Brown no one wants to go there anyway so
when Joe says that oh I have no idea
about my son's business dealings he's
obviously lying I told you that
yesterday and I remembered it look
here's the thing Biden was still the
vice president when his son went into
business with the CEO of that Chinese
Energy company okay he writes the letter
for this kid would pay apparently when
he left office but it doesn't matter
here's what we need we need a a special
counsel this cannot be handled by
Merrick Garland I think right now based
upon the emails that we have seen we
need to have an investigation not just
of Hunter Biden but of Joe Biden because
of Joe Biden's bills are being paid for
by Hunter Biden if Joe Biden is bringing
his son to China and his son is making
money after meeting on uh Air Force Air
Force 2 in China and if the email which
there has already been questions about
in the grand jury as to who H is or who
the big guy is if there's already hard
testimony in terms of the witness who
wrote the email that's this guy Jillian
we don't know what his answer is but we
know from Tony bobolinski who was on
that email that the big guy was Joe
Biden so if you don't believe that ask
yourself why would the money be held by
Hunter for the big guy so are although
the president's two defenses have blown
up that he doesn't talk to his son about
business and Hunter never took money
from the Chinese they've blown up it's
blown so where we go from here Hunter
Biden is or at least was a pig and he
was so unmotivated that he didn't even
have the energy after giving his
computer to the Delaware repair shop to
pick it up
what I want to know though and I think
is far more interesting than than
flailing around about special
prosecutors and so forth
remembering that well we don't play I
mean no I don't disgusting I I withdraw
the bird to flail I withdraw that
because you're not a flailer but uh
remember when the 51 intelligence yes
operatives signed a letter that said the
hunter Biden emails are likely Russian
disinformation 51 of our brightest
Intelligence Officers said it was
Russian likely Russian disinformation
where are they now the Senate Judiciary
Committee wants to know where are where
are these 51 experts who said Ah that's
phone it's fake during the height of an
election it's funny it's fake forget
about it
where are you now yeah and you consider
how they track down everybody that
showed up at the Capitol on January 6th
but they don't know where the
worthy somebody who does who doesn't
correct oh sorry I just I just I just
realized that no one has ever asked me
for a letter of recommendation and that
includes my niece and nephew and they
and like I was pretty successful yeah
but they I guess they knew that it
wouldn't it would write a good letter I
would write a good letter I'm a pretty
decent writer but you know when you
consider the laptop story and you
consider the collusion you know episode
the collusion myth it's the Democrats of
media and the Intel agencies working
together and it's almost like their own
shadow government in a way that they can
create a story or they can eliminate a
story they get it to the media who
amplifies it or disappears it it impacts
the American public and then we kind of
do with the shadow government wants us
to do we vote for Joe Biden because
that's exactly was the was the result
from all of this and it makes sense it
and it changes the way you look at
everything I mean it's like you have the
Russian collusion laptop Insurrection
find people hoax drinking bleach don't
say gay all of these things are these
manufactured stories so when you so it's
nobody's fault if you don't believe
anything anymore right and if somebody's
skeptical skeptical of your beliefs then
you believe them even more because you
think they're full of crap do you think
Jen saki believes what her boss Joe
Biden is telling her at this point
because you look at her body language
and her facial expression and I read
body language Dana Sarah living on the
side You Can Tell She's a uncomfortable
and you can tell she knows she's not
telling the truth but she's pushing the
party line I think it's I think is what
she has been told right so has she been
told the truth I don't know I do think I
don't think she's lying but that doesn't
square with everything that's been
reported about Joe's knowledge right if
I got the payments and I understand why
they always say gotta call the doj gotta
call now that will last until it doesn't
and that's one of the reasons the New
York Post today said that there should
be a special counsel because let's say
that there's a plea deal
and part of the plea deal is the
evidence goes away then then nobody will
ever know and so it'll be a continued
mystery that's one of those reasons a
couple things on that Miranda Divine
this morning on Fox and Friends said
that the letter the letter of
recommendation was not very effective
the kid did not get it so that I mean
everybody keeps missing I feel like
we're burying the league
it's not taken seriously by anybody oh
good the money that they sent the Biden
family did I also talked to a couple of
people today in the intelligence
Community one is retired who said that
they were they were getting so many
requests to join the other 51 and
there's like probably 10 000 people who
are given this request to sign on and
only these 51 and if you look at the 51
it's not like it's just intelligence
officials they all have I shouldn't say
all if you look through you could like
Democratic connections all the way
throughout and they can't be found Jerry
Dunleavy I believe at the Washington
examiner he's keeping track he calls all
of them all the time he's like hey do
you um do you guys want to comment now
and they always say no the last point I
want to make is that the left has been
leaning in really hard to try to say
that Ginny Thomas is so influential over
her husband and this is in regards to
her text messages to the former Chief of
Staff to Trump about election Integrity
in 2020. but I imagine that the Biden
family is like I don't think we want to
set that standard it's not exactly the
standard we want to be going
one more thing
isn't it obscene how it wasn't until the
Washington Post or the New York Times
affirmed that the computer was real and
the emails were real that that was a
release for the rest of the media to say
okay yeah I mean what happened for two
years I mean because now because now I
mean they suppressed it to get him in
now they're releasing it to get him out
oh line of the night hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else